Okay, here's my answer.
What I do is I make a variable called markers,
which is going to be a bunch of strings of the format of 'markers = %s, %s',
substituting in the lat and long for p and points.
Then we're going to join those together with an ampersand,
and then we're just going to append that to the base URL. Simple enough.
Okay, if I were to run this with just a single point, it still needs to be in a list.
Our function is still expecting a list but one point.
Make up some fake coordinates here and give this a run.
We see that this also works just fine-- "markers=100,200',
and there's this one markers parameter.
Let's go ahead and use this in our program.